on a eu envie aussi de le voir son avis
sur le mouvement des gilet jaune nous a
répondu bien sûr par en évoquant
également les casseurs que l'on dit
parfois d'extrême-droite
regardez nous en voyons pas non vois que
vous ètes cravate orange aujourd'hui est
ce que vous considérez comme gilet jaune
je ne suis pas agi les jaunes j'ai
trouvé que c'était un mouvement spontané
étonnant par sa naissance d'abord parce
que très vite les la manifestation a
pris des proportions considérables
ces gens là ne pense pas la même chose
sur la plupart des problèmes mais ils
ont en commun c'est le gilet jaune et
j'ai dit le vrai chef des mouvements
c'est le vilain est vrai il ne pense pas
malheureusement et ne parle pas on sait
bien que les gens de l'extrême gauche
sont sont ceux qui créent des les
problèmes dans la manifestation parle de
gens d'extrême libyen pas de gens de
l'extrême d'entremont site considéré
c'est ce que disent certains gilet jaune
ils disent qu'il ya derrière il y avait
là il ya déjà des casseurs qui ont
intégré mouvement des jeunes des
casseurs d'extrême droite n'ont aucune
c'est ce que leur large et je ne crois
pas du tout il n'existe aucun mouvement
radical d'extrême droit n'existe pas en
france il n'y a aucun mouvement radical
d'extrême orient connaît pas ça n'existe
pas tous les cas je